hot breath our first question from
christian williams asks can you speak
on making the transition from stand-up
to acting and voice acting
and what is your favorite show or movie
you've gotten to work on
oh okay yeah um first i will say
that like it's so
they're so different they're very
different jobs
and but what you what's different about
them is just kind of like the technical
speak
and and not knowing terms it's kind of
like it's a lot
a lot of different industries like
whether you're in a medical industry or
you're a lawyer
there's these terms that you know that
other
you know civilians don't know so when i
first was going from stand up to acting
there were things that scared me like
when people say hey turn camera aside i
did not know what that meant
uh hit your hit your mark i did not know
what that meant
and so that was the scary part of it
but coming from stand up it gave me this
background of like
okay i can look at it i can look at
these scenes like
jokes and i can look at my my my lines
as
they're my set list you know and i've
done that kind of what
everything i do i try not to betray my
base in my background like even
when i write um i try to write my own
series i try to write different
so a few pilots but if you go into my
initial like drafts they're kind of like
sets
they're just like this this is the order
this is the end this is you know
it's one two three four like it's a set
because i
that's how i learned to write and so i
kind of take that with acting and voice
acting as well
one of the biggest lessons i learn
and some of the best advice i can give
is to stay humble and to not
think success in one area means that you
have success in the other area but that
it does mean that you can have a base
like i know i'm funny so
i was like okay that i can learn the
rest i know i'm funny i know i'm likable
i know i'm
people want to watch me so i the rest i
can learn
and that's what i would say learn it go
to acting class
have a respect for it if you truly want
to do it because that that's what i did
as soon as i moved to la
within six months i was in acting class
and i've been in acting class
continuously since then like i don't i
don't
leave like i i know i don't have a
respect for people
who don't respect the craft like to me
it's such a blessing to have these jobs
to have that opportunity
and i always know i hated it when an
actor or a wrestler
or somebody came in to stand up and then
they were like oh yeah i remember i
would talk to some wrestlers and like oh
i've tried stand up the first show i did
was an hour
and it's just like well you didn't you
didn't really do santa
you got on stage and you told some
stories until you left
you know so like i don't have respect
for that and i knew i didn't want to
be that as an actor i didn't want to
come in and have actors be like oh this
guy doesn't
he's just mugging and just hitting lines
he doesn't
care he doesn't know about the arc he
doesn't know about his intentions he
doesn't know anything
like that so i stay in class and i think
one of the
major differences that my acting teacher
taught me um was that
and it helped my stand up actually is
that stand-ups are usually taught to
stay above their feelings
and to just comment on the situation and
that doesn't work for acting
you have to be in your body you have to
be in your feelings you have to go
on the journey you know that's why
seinfeld is a great
comedian and great on his show but he's
not a great actor
because he doesn't go into any feelings
and so i learned that i wanted to do
that and then i kind of would say oh
like i can take those feelings and then
use that
in my stand up so now i'm i'm not only
getting laughs i'm taking you on this
journey i'm making you
feel i'm making i'm talking to you about
my son i'm talking to you about my life
i'm making you care about me and to me
that's
like just as powerful as getting a big
laugh
and his i don't know better answer your
question oh for sure
no that no that was very thorough thank
you so much for sharing that
because i went to the second part which
was the the favorites my
favorites that i've done so far
um i really loved acting with dan harmon
uh i did a thing with him uh called
great minds where i
got to be idi amin and just his process
of like when i showed up there they
didn't even have a script like
he was just like this this is what we're
thinking about let's
work it out together and then we'll
figure it out and i feel like it was
probably some of my best acting because
of that um i really liked my role in
future man because i liked
i thought i did some solid acting there
and
um i say my voiceovers harley quinn like
i i
think that's like super funny and a
really good show and and
just some of my best work